they were the ones that were bullying me
it wasn't the boys it was always the
girls i held on to the insecurity so any
time i saw an incredible woman it just
became a reflection of how incompetent i
felt that i was envy can be something
that you see someone have but it
inspires you right it's like well we're
freaking danican danica can do it and so
can i you know and she's come from
nowhere and by golly i can do it too but
that's freaking empowering and envy can
be beautiful but jealousy to your point
can tell you apart you just feel worse
about yourself being around that person
and you know it is something that you
strive for but it really just reflects
why you haven't gotten it versus which i
use now is like a beautiful inspiration
i was insecure with myself and it wasn't
until i started working on my own
mindset and how i felt about myself and
taking ownership over stepping up to the
plate with bad in hand and swinging as
hard as i can even if i missed that gave
me the encouragement to be like how did
she do it maybe i can do it too